[Music]
hello and welcome to Hollywood we've
come to the world-famous Universal
Studios who are behind four out of the
nine films nominated for Best Picture
darkest hour get out
Lady Bird and phantom threads we'll be
finding out about them and all the major
nominees in the next half an hour it
just feels like there's something bigger
to be said everyone has their own truth
it's amazing to see that the majority of
the best ones this year have female
protagonists at the heart of them very
strong female leaders so that happen
spontaneously what has happened in the
last three or four months is an epic
event a woman sort of integrity and rage
and power you through that can working
characters I mean the sparks flying
[Music]
Oh truly creative because I don't know
what would happen next
I'm an elemental miss submissive and
that's why better that's one of the
great stories in human history this is
the 90th Oscars and over the years
they've been tears triumphs and total
surprises he's long been a platform for
political sentiments but this year
something totally unprecedented has been
happening as our la correspondent Greg
Milam reports the post weinstein
reckoning will be felt this weekend
last year's winner for best actor Casey
Affleck facing harassment allegations of
his own will not as his tradition
present an award and the Academy faces
criticism over whites expelled Weinstein
but not others like convicted sex
offender Roman Polanski the man who took
over as president two months before the
Weinstein scandal broke Harvey Weinstein
was like it was like a you know a
seismic eruption that particular
situation had a gravity and a depth of
misbehavior in conduct that was so
evident it had to be addressed you know
and it was ongoing an immediate in terms
of Polanski in terms of some other names
that have come up I mean the reality is
yes some of these people have won Oscars
even you know well we'll just have to
see you know what happens as we move
forward over the last six months we've
learned a lot about the other side of
Hollywood
behind the facade the hidden world of
dark secrets and the change that's
happening here as a result is also
having an effect way beyond the
entertainment industry for people a long
way from the spotlight hi Jen Pugh was
Meryl Streep's guest at the Golden
Globes an activist for domestic workers
she says that that message that times up
across the board is real the choice to
include all of these different
constituencies that were the kind of
communities that were represented by
activists at the Golden Globes to me was
a very intentional choice to say the
kind of movement we want to be a part of
and bill
is one that is inclusive and that really
does advance the interests and improve
life for all women and all people but it
will be about Hollywood this weekend and
a reminder that whatever is changing
here the people who make the movies
spend millions on winning because
winning matters in Hollywood I'm now
joined by Gregg Milam and Melissa
silverstein from women in Hollywood's
great to see you both Melissa how will
the time's up campaign be reflected on
the carpet and during the ceremony well
I think that times up campaign is
reflecting in everything that's been
going on in the industry and so while we
don't know what people will be seeing on
the carpet or at their interviews I
think it has it has overwhelmed the
conversation and also it's just it's
just pervasive in the industry now Greg
is there any indications about how the
ceremony will be conducted as anyone
said anything about that well we saw the
president of the Academy John Bailey
they're talking about what's going on in
the industry and his seismic shift as he
described it I think they know it will
be mentioned on the stage certainly they
tried a very careful line and saying
well who knows what people will say when
they get up there to accept an award but
I think it would be very odd if it
wasn't reflected in some of those
speeches and perhaps in some of the
questions as Melissa says on the red
carpet and in the interview room because
it is such a big deal for the industry
and we've seen in all the other award
shows something that can't be ignored do
you think the culture is changing though
do you think that things like The Times
up campaign will give women the strength
to come forward and just not put up with
these types of things anymore women just
want to work they want to work in a safe
environment they want to be successful
they want to have opportunities to get
these jobs this is really simple thing
and by the way sexual harassment has
been illegal in this country for thirty
years this is not news that this has
been going on but now what is happening
if people are paying attention to it in
a much more significant way and
hopefully we're gonna see better
protections thank you both so much and
now we have been speaking to a few of
this year's nominees about how they see
the future for women here in Hollywood I
do think that it you know
if they're if it's visibility or if the
idea of me as a role model helps to get
more women behind the camera then it's
then it's you know then I'll do anything
to make that happen
so I'm really honored to be in that
position and hopefully pull more people
out of the trenches you know everyone's
making a conscious effort to have female
storytellers tell those stories and I
think this is such a strong year for
films anyway but it's amazing to see
that the majority the best films this
year have female protagonists at the
heart of them we're all still address
and off we haven't stopped that but
there's less attention being hot on you
know what one person is wearing versus
another at that whole thing was like who
wore it best and you know while the Best
Picture frontrunners are female LED
films three take on historical men as
Greg Milam reports on board the famous
old line of the Queen Mary now a hotel
in California you find the sets for the
movie of the darkest hour aboard a ship
on which Churchill sailed three times
during the war you can examine up-close
the meticulous attention to detail of
the movie makers in recreating the
cabinet war rooms the man who plays
Churchill may well pick up the Best
Actor Oscar this year a reward for his
own transformation for the part I'm
nearly 60 and I thought I'm not going to
gain 70 pounds I spent the rest of my
life actually losing weight so we always
knew that there would be some makeup we
found I think a nice balance
there's another World War two epic in
the running of course and the director
of Dunkirk says filmmakers have a duty
to be faithful to the facts you can't
help but feel the responsibility to tell
this story with respect to history I
started to feel that knowing as I do the
artifice that has to be applied to
characters at the center of the story
like this to make the story clear to the
audience to give them the right
information of course Hollywood is
generally all about make-believe and it
does have a history of messing with well
history but with more and more biopic
being made in films about real historic
significant events and with so much
focus on whether we can believe what
we're seeing on our screens there is a
responsibility on filmmakers to tell the
truth well we cannot reach them whether
any of this bothers the Academy judges
will soon find out the betting though
suggests this performance will bring
Gary Oldman's acting career its finest
hour
now we've moved location to the set of
psycho which was nominated for four
Oscars in 1961 darkest hour is up for
six and I'm delighted to say I am joined
by its producer at Lisa Bruce Lisa
lovely to see you
congratulations six nominations you must
be so delighted yeah it's great it's
really exciting I mean it's the film has
really been embraced by sort of a global
audience and that's the best part and
it's really an honor to be nominated for
six yeah what do you think it is about
the film that struck such a chord with
aces and audience you know it's
interesting to make a movie that's set
in 1940 but feels so relevant today and
I think a lot of that has to do with you
know a sort of a need for us to sort of
find a strong leader that is very clear
on their vision and very articulate and
and Winston Churchill was very clear in
this one moment in his prime
ministership as he stood up against
Hitler and I think that just moves
people and what were the challenges in
doing a film that was based on real-life
events yeah so we were involved quite a
lot with the Churchill family so we got
details from them we the the writer
Anthony Martin did a ton of research and
then we brought in researchers as well
as historians and then the art
department led by Sarah Greenwood is one
of the best in the world really and Joe
that's Joe
right steam Joe radar director and what
they did was they got very very detailed
about John just the veracity of the sets
the details of the sets but but human
details from people's Diaries and from
people's stories and from talking to
people that actually had been in the
Church of war rooms and we built the
whole Churchill war rooms and then we
also built the whole House of Commons
which was just amazing and then Joe
Wright the way he works as he filled the
House of Commons up not with you know we
didn't do digital extras or we didn't do
people against green screen that was 500
extras all dressed in period 1940 you
know all the way down to the underwear
so I think it makes everybody feel very
very much in that actual period and then
it evokes that I think to an audience
and Gary Oldman I mean he is so
sensational and presumably had to spend
about seven days in makeup to look like
you're not so right honest I mean it was
months of research and tests with an
amazing artist by the name by the
nickname of kazoo and he was at three
hours every single day in hair and
makeup and then by the time he was in
wardrobe it's like three and a half and
every single day and yeah he doesn't
he's doesn't look anything like Gary
Oldman and this year the Oscars is very
much focused on women women led felt
female led films and also women in the
industry as a female producer working in
Hollywood how does that feel it's gotta
see it feels like it's about time I mean
right where 50% of the population as
women and largely up until even a year
ago I would say most material is
generated by men it's governed by men
the funders or men largely and it's not
that they have an agenda but when you
don't have females creating the material
creating the source and then directing
it and and governing how that's made you
don't naturally have a female you have a
natural female voice that feels
authentic and I think both also for
people of color it's changing because
there's more diversity in media and I
hope that will continue it's at least
how positive are you about the future
you know it does honestly feel like for
the first time in my career that it's
actually changing because I think people
are now really looking at having
material that is not just written by
women but also directed by women
and produced by women and I think that
that will bring a whole different level
of storytelling I mean up until now I
feel like a lot of female characters are
kind of ornamental mm-hmm they're there
because you're supposed to have a woman
and they ought you know in the house or
in the in the office but they're not
really written in a way that feels like
a truthful representation I think that's
really changing and it's crazy because
it makes good business sense half the
population is going to the movies yeah
women exactly
hello and welcome back you join us in
Hollywood at Universal Studios and this
is the studio behind many of this year's
Oscar nominated films doors of course
won three Academy Awards in 1976 and its
director Steven Spielberg is no stranger
to the madness of award season his film
the post is this year in the running for
Best Picture set in the 70s it focuses
on the Washington Post decision to
publish the Pentagon Papers secret
documents about the Vietnam War which
exposed years of government deception it
reminded me of things that are happening
right now in terms of in terms of the
media being broadsided by the admitted
by this administration and and being
labeled if they're not pleased with the
coverage new sources are being called
fake or fake news is a new kind of you
know hashtag that's out there these days
and I found that oh my god when I read
the script I said Wow Nixon did the same
thing but without a Twitter account the
post stars Meryl Streep and Tom Hanks
both Giants in an industry currently
reeling from allegations of sexual abuse
and misconduct what has happened in the
last three or four months is an epic
event this is not just another little
blip on the news cycle this is something
that's not going to be yesterday's news
in 24 hours from now this is a watershed
moment and and extolling the virtues of
women coming forward through tremendous
personal sacrifice using tremendous
amounts of courage to speak about what
happened to them yesterday or 40 years
ago it doesn't matter
now to the films and who will win what
and I am joined by Hollywood Reporter's
Stevie Wong and Amy Nicholson great to
see you though hello now starting with
the directors know what nomination for
Steven Spielberg know who would have
thought here we are on the jaws said
that Steven Spielberg is the underdog at
this year's Oscar race in a film at Tom
Hanks and Meryl Streep it I think to me
it just shows how much the Oscars are
changing and how fast I was also
surprised that Martin McDonagh didn't
get a nomination for three billboards
that's one of the favorites isn't my
daughter Angela was murdered seven
months ago it seems to me the police
department is too busy torturing black
folks and he and Krispy Kremes to solve
actual crime but the fact that these two
kind of frontrunners and other awards
ceremonies they're not ended in the five
we pit allows us to have critical Rick
in the list now we also get to an appeal
and I know you're a huge fan in history
to be nominated as Best Director it's
true you know I think that a lot of
times Best Director goes to the person
who looks like they did the most they
have the most costumes and explosions
and military things but the idea that
they're recognizing somebody who just
made a fantastic ensemble piece who can
direct actors that well to me that's
what we should be rewarding just as much
as somebody does something more showy
another makeup of the Academy has
changed in the last few years do you
think that's has an effect on this
year's nominations cuz on the surface it
does seem to be more diverse it's an
extremely diverse now much more so than
maybe two years ago and so the hashtag
of Oscars away it still might play a
little bit but the fact that you know
all the different categories that we're
seeing differences and that's a nice
thing for us to admire I absolutely
agree I mean in the last year's the
Academy added thousands deliberately
thousands of younger younger
representatives people of color because
if we were here two years ago we would
have said oh the Academy it's a bunch of
old white guys now I feel like
especially in categories like Best
Director you see these new members
fighting to redefine what an Oscar film
is yet because we got married egg whites
from mud bounds she's a fantastic
nominee she's nominated in two
categories there's lots of history made
made for this year's Oscars isn't it
I won't be working for them happy focus
you know for her to be that supporting
actress and also she's gonna perform
hopefully at the Oscars with her song
yeah her performance in London is
spectacular because she just she carries
herself like a diva I mean this is a
woman who is able to stand in front of
stadiums and channel emotions through
with a microphone and a song she does
that here in a small scale you know what
her character and my band is thinking
even when she's not acting in the most
deliberate way and talking about Brits I
think we have how many nominations 20
good that's solid I mean use your
spreader and all the acting categories I
think you're very likely to win at least
one my bet is maybe Gary Oldman for Best
Actor what about Sally Hawkins that she
is in shape of water which leaves the
nominations in 13 is she got chance I
don't think so I mean as much as I'd
like her performance and that I feel
like you know Frances McGovern has
really kind of won every single word and
it's gonna be really difficult for her
to not pick this one they are but I
think so he has yes I do think she has a
chance I like I would not be on the
floor gasping in astonishment if she won
because honestly they're just knocked
out that a woman who doesn't speak at
all I was able to do so much in that
film three billboards we can also claim
it's a British film it's made by British
producers isn't it so I think that's
counting the littlest bit against it all
of a sudden because the conversations
you're hearing among voters is who's
this British guy to come in and make a
movie
explaining American racism to us I think
they're a little touchy about it I think
that's the up Road Hill that Martin
McDonagh has to say like I have a right
to write about this I have a perspective
and so who will gasp Best Picture
because coming into this three
billboards we thought was the favorite
but I mean we will actually walk away
with the Oscar I don't think so
and we have the sudden we were talking
about this how you as a as a in the
nominee ballot you can choose your top
three films or maybe even more and so I
feel that people who like three
billboards are gonna put out some BER
one but always the number two would be
shape above water and by default
everybody's number two and number one I
think shapes gonna just pick up based on
like the numbers that they're collecting
from everybody else which is like water
will walk away with last year if you
want a reward like an indie film that
took a big risk you were all going for
moonlight this year it's it's scattered
nobody can decide now from Hollyoaks to
hollywood's former soap star Rachel
Simpson is Oscar nominated for her short
film it's all huge congratulations on
your nomination I'll tell us what was
the inspiration for this film yeah my
lovely dad lived the last two years of
his life the family death he lost his
hearing very suddenly so I saw firsthand
the huge effect that has on a person in
a family and and got involved with the
deaf community learned sign language and
kind of fell in love with it really the
language itself is beautiful and the
deaf community are a real community of
their own and and as I got more exposed
to it I saw the barriers that deaf
children and deaf people face the
needless barriers actually and and that
gave me the impetus to write the script
you're an actress so how do you go from
being a successful actress to writing an
oscar-nominated for him I mean I suppose
this is one of those things I did feel
did undo probably and feel under
qualified to write excitin anything
before and kind of had that I call it
imposter syndrome you know like and well
how can I do this I've never done
anything before but I felt so so
passionately about the subject and that
it's a story that needed to be told that
I kind of thought well I'll just give it
a go and my is my fiance is Chris
everything the director of the project
who kind of really forced me to actually
put pen to paper and write it and he
said just send it to me cuz if it's
rubbish you know what I'll never see it
he was delicious and so I did yeah and
when you found out you were nominated I
mean what on earth was that like so few
people in the world will ever have that
feeling it's so crazy even you just
saying it then feels crazy I didn't feel
like it's even happening and so surreal
such a surreal moment and because a
short film obviously then it's obviously
a labor of love they're done on a
shoestring there's no financial gain
from a short film so it just feels like
such a long process of them and and you
never know if there's gonna be any
rewards and you know you don't do it for
that for that reason at all and so when
there are are and this happens it's just
extra special and very interesting for
you to be here this year in particular
when there's so much of the spotlight is
on women yeah does it feel special yeah
I think it kind of does there are a lot
of conversations that were just going on
I feel it's a good time for women right
now it's a good year for women it's a
good year for diversity and I think it's
actually really important to remember
that disability falls in the diversity
bracket as well it's a it's a community
people that are hugely represented in
film and so very proud that our movie
represents that as well
and don't forget you can watch the Oscar
ceremony along Yvonne sky cinema on
Sunday night and join me on Sky News
with all the winners from the Vanity
Fair party from 6 o'clock on Monday
morning
you
[Music]